Researcher Ellis was having a very long day.
Working at the SCP Foundation can sound like
a pretty exciting job to an outsider.
The problem is, when you deal with something
exciting every day of your life, it starts
to become as mundane as brushing your teeth,
or pouring your morning bowl of breakfast
cereal.
Over time, everything loses its magic.
She had the unenviable job of double-checking
the anomalies in C-Wing of Site-77.
Glorified box-ticking.
She trudged from containment chamber to containment
chamber, everything seeming to be in order.
Tick, tick, tick.
It was all Euclid and Safe Class anomalies
anyway, hardly major containment risks.
But when she reached the chamber for SCP-2805,
the security cameras normally used to observe
the anomaly were on the fritz.
She’d need to go inside.
Great.
When the chamber doors opened, she felt an
immediate chill.
Her breath came out as an icy fog.
In the distance, she saw a jar sitting on
a podium, the glass so frosted over she couldn’t
quite make out what was inside.
No sign of a containment breach.
She ticked the box next to SCP-2805 on her
clipboard, and moved on.
Several hours later, Researcher Ellis was
at home, finally able to relax.
Since she started working at the Foundation,
dealing with deadly creatures and cursed artifacts
on a daily basis, she’d longed for the simple
comforts of childhood in her downtime.
That’s why she decided to spend her evening
with a warm mug of hot chocolate, a bowl of
ice cream, and her favorite animated Disney
movie, Mulan.
She had just pressed play when she got a phone
call from an unknown number.
With a frustrated groan, she picked up the
phone and answered.
The voice on the other end was a little gravelly
but it sounded kind.
His diction was old-fashioned, a man from
a bygone era.
“Why hello there, young lady, I hope this
isn’t a bad time,” he said.
“The name’s Walt.
Walt Disney.
Perhaps you’ve seen one of my motion pictures.
I was wondering if I could trouble you for
some help with a project of mine.”
This must have been some stupid prank call,
maybe Dr. Bright or Dr. Clef was bored and
decided they wanted to mess with her.
The fact that she was watching a Disney movie
at the time was pure coincidence.
After all, they own half the movies out there
these days.
But that’s when “Walt” carried on talking
to her.
“You see, my dear, I’m a little short
on time at the moment, I realize I, perhaps,
um, don’t have the longevity that I used
to.
I won’t get into the illness right now,
but what I do know is that I may not be able
to put my final idea into practice.
And I believe that you, and your organization,
may be able to help.
Your - what is it called - SCP Foundation?”
And that changed everything.
Researcher Ellis immediately knew that this
wasn’t a prank call.
A member of Foundation staff would never discuss
Foundation matters, even as a joke, over an
unsecured line.
And a civilian would have no reason to even
know about the Foundation.
Was she actually on the phone with the Walt
Disney.
It seemed odd and more than a little unlikely
on account of him having been dead for over
fifty years.
If only Researcher Ellis had checked her clipboard
a little closer.
Then maybe she would have realized that she
was already under the anomalous effects of
SCP-2805 - also humorously known as “Disney
on Ice.”
Here’s a fun question for you: What’s
your favorite Disney movie?
Probably not what you expected to hear from
your friends at SCP Explained, but seriously,
we want to know - tell us down in the comments.
Maybe you’re a classical purist, and you
consider Snow White, Cinderella, or Sleeping
Beauty to be the best.
Maybe you’re a fan of the Disney Renaissance,
and it’s The Little Mermaid, Beauty and
the Beast, or The Lion King tha are the true
masterpieces.
Or perhaps you’re a fan of their more modern
outings, like Tangled, Frozen, and Moana,
or even their acquisitions, like Marvel movies
or the Star Wars series.
We could go on, but honestly, we’d be here
all day.
The Walt Disney Company, started by Walter
Elias Disney and his brother, Roy, back in
1923, has become one of the most powerful
and influential entertainment companies in
existence.
Their corporate machine is so huge and sprawling,
it rivals the size and scope of the SCP Foundation
itself, and it’s influenced the way we look
at everything from mice to pirates to Norse
legends to space battles.
Some give the United States’ President the
title “Leader of the Free World”, but
anyone in that position would happily drop
everything to take a phone call from the CEO
of the Walt Disney Company, even today.
The company may be a global superpower these
days, but none of it would have been possible
without Walt himself.
Born in 1901, Walt started his legendary company
at the tender age of 22.
Who would have known he would leave such an
indelible mark on human culture during his
65 years of life.
But he’s not just an entrepreneur, animator,
writer, voice actor, and film producer, he’s
also, decades after his death, an anomaly
currently in the capable hands of the SCP
Foundation.
Well, his cryogenically frozen severed head
is, anyway.
And simply looking at that severed head, is
what put such an anomalous damper on Researcher
Ellis’ nice, quiet evening.
Confused?
Don’t worry.
Let’s start this demented Disney fairytale
at the beginning - by which we mean, The End
- of Walt Disney’s life.
Walt Disney accomplished more in his life
than many of us would be able to claim in
several lifetimes.
He’d built one of the most enduring entertainment
companies of all time, won countless awards,
and made millions of dollars from his creations
- including the Disneyland theme parks.
The man had essentially made his own name
synonymous with magic, childhood whimsy, and
dreams coming true.
However, rather than focusing on the past,
Walt wanted to keep his eyes on the future.
His grand vision went far beyond movies and
theme parks: He wanted to shape the way humanity
lived for centuries to come.
And the name of this vision?
EPCOT, or the Experimental Prototype Community
of Tomorrow.
While you may know EPCOT as a mere portion
of the theme park in the Florida Walt Disney
Resort, Walt himself actually intended it
to be so much more.
As the full name suggests, he dreamed of creating
a functional community of tomorrow, with over
20,000 residents.
In his own words:
"EPCOT will take its cue from the new ideas
and new technologies that are now emerging
from the creative centers of American industry.
It will be a community of tomorrow that will
never be completed but will always be introducing
and testing, and demonstrating new materials
and new systems.
And EPCOT will always be a showcase to the
world of the ingenuity and imagination of
American free enterprise."
It was certainly a utopian idea - though fans
of Bioshock may find their eye twitching with
flashbacks to Andrew Ryan’s disastrous Rapture.
However, Disney’s problem didn’t lie in
his plans, but in himself.
Despite his achievements and larger-than-life
legacy, he was still a mortal man.
When Walt tragically contracted lung cancer,
he finally became aware of the fact that he
may not live to see his beautiful EPCOT dream
completed.
And despite having all the money and fame
a man could possibly ask for, he was beginning
to realize that his fortune couldn’t buy
him a second of extra time...Or could it?
This question would soon be answered when
representatives of a mysterious company known
as The Oneiroi Collective approached Walt.
The strange thing, though, was that the entities
that comprise this elusive Group of Interest
contacted Walt in his dreams.
You see, the Oneiroi Collective are a group
of entities known as the Oneiroi, or Dreamers,
who exist only in the dreamspace - but sometimes
interact with our world through anomalous,
sometimes semi-organic creations they sell
as products.
In that sense, they were the original Imagineers.
Their creations include SCP-2028, a few hundred
snow globes that allow the user to remove
and store their nightmares and negative feelings
within.
And SCP-1498, which are creatures made from
old-fashioned rotary phones trailing a huge
number of wires, coiled and arranged into
sheep-like bodies.
By calling the phone on the creature’s face,
a person can order a custom dreamscape from
the Oneiroi.
Naturally, as creatures who depend on dreams
to survive, the Oneiroi were big fans of Walt
Disney - a man who’d built a career on encouraging
children to dream their little hearts out.
In exchange for his contributions to the Dreamscape,
they’d cut him a deal: They’d give him
a special kind of Oneiroi technology that
would allow his consciousness to continue
to exist and interact with the physical realm
after his death.
All they’d need to keep was his head.
It was certainly a strange deal, but Walt
was thinking of his children, his grandchildren,
and their children and grandchildren.
If he died now, then his Tomorrowland dreams
would die with him.
He’d simply be known for some charming animated
films and a couple of amusing theme parks,
not for truly changing the future.
It seemed that the deal with the Oneiroi Collective
was too good to resist.
The deal was struck, and arrangements were
made to preserve Disney’s head and consciousness
after his death.
Ten days after his 65th birthday, on December
15th, 1966, Walt Disney passed away.
But that was only the beginning of his new,
anomalous life.
While the public mourned, Disney’s head
was secretly removed and preserved in a jar
with anomalous cryonics technology.
The device is also fixed to a pair of rotary
phones - a trademark of the Oneiroi - and
an inscription that reads, “Siberian Solutions
from the Oneiroi Collective.”
The anomalous effect was simple: Anyone who
looked directly at Disney’s frozen head
would receive a phone call in the next 24
hours.
This phone call would be from Walt Disney
himself, presumably inhabiting the Oneiroi
Dreamscape now.
With this handy trick, he’d be able to maintain
his communications with the rest of the Walt
Disney Company in secret, and see the creation
of his precious EPCOT project to its completion.
But unfortunately, that’s not actually how
it happened.
Following Walt’s “death”, his brother,
Roy, took over all Walt Disney Company operations.
While the profitability of the company didn’t
suffer under Roy’s control, Walt’s final
dream did.
EPCOT mutated from the sustainable, functional
community of the future that Walt desired,
into a mere theme park - the Disney-fied World’s
Fair that all Orlando Disney park visitors
of today would recognize.
As it turned out, most people in the Disney
company weren’t actually eager to take orders
from the former CEO’s severed head.
As a result, he became kind of a dark company
secret, hidden away within the Disney parks.
After a number of reports of calls from Walt
Disney after the entrepreneur's death, the
Foundation finally started to take notice.
They conducted a thorough investigation of
the various Disney bases of operation, and
eventually found Disney’s frozen head - soon
redesignated SCP-2805 - in a secret compartment
in the legendary Pirates of the Caribbean
ride.
He was relocated to Site-77 soon after for
further testing, where his anomalous abilities
were later discovered.
Sadly for SCP-2805, while his calls to Foundation
staff have all consisted of attempts in enlisting
the Foundation’s help in making his EPCOT
dreams a reality, nobody has yet taken him
up on the offer.
Since his containment, the Foundation’s
main priority has just been suppressing conspiracy
theories about the existence of Walt Disney’s
cryogenically frozen head, a task which they
undertake with collaboration from the Disney
company.
In order to muddy the waters, in 1981, they
began productions of Walt Disney's World on
Ice, later known as Disney on Ice, a traveling
ice skating show.
Since then, they also released the incredibly
successful film “Frozen” and its sequel,
to corrupt any searches for key phrases like
“Disney’s Frozen” or “Walt Ice.”
It’s been an incredibly effective smokescreen,
as you can probably expect from the SCP Foundation,
and sadly for Walt and fans of a midcentury
perspective on the future, it’s likely that
Walt Disney’s dreams will stay within his
disembodied head.
So if you’re hoping to prove the existence
of this truly wild anomaly, or somehow get
in contact with Walt and help him to bring
EPCOT to its intended glory, you should probably
just Let It Go.
Now go check out “SCP-343 - God” and “A
Sea Snail's Fantasy SCP-1867 - A Gentleman”
for more SCPs you can have a truly stimulating
conversation with!